living in a fast-paced digital world
it's easy to become completely
disconnected from nature but no matter
where you are there are plenty of
natural wonders to find all you have to
do is stop for a moment and look I bet
you've got a seashell somewhere at home
in the bathroom or on a bookshelf or
venture into your garden or local park
follow the silvery trails and you should
easily find an animal living inside an
elegant spiral shells are enduring links
to another world that begins on our
doorsteps and stretches to remote
corners of the planet there the vacated
homes of an amazing group of animals the
mollusks including riffing from oysters
and snails to strange creatures like sea
butterflies and Argonauts there are
mollusks living in the deepest oceans to
the tops of mountains and just about
everywhere in between and they've been
around for a very long time their direct
ancestors were roaming the Seas more
than half a billion years ago so that
beautiful object in your hand connects
you not only to the natural world today
but deep into the past to a time long
before us humans and our busy lives came
along
you